foreign
coal is in Wichita Kansas hey Cole
welcome to the Ramsey Show
hey Dave
hi I'm uh I'm proud to be on here with
you I think uh for your time honored to
have you how can we help
well I messed up so
um
we are in the hole big time I mean I
guess not big time we're on our way
there
um and I don't know
what to attack first I guess
um what we're going to do we're selling
one of the vehicles
um it's it's got some problems that are
coming to arise that I've noticed and uh
so we're just gonna sell that one
um
whatever money we have left over we're
gonna save a thousand of it for our
emergency fund
and
then start applying whatever else we
have to the rest
um basically what I don't know what to
do is like looking ahead to the end of
this month
um
I'm gonna be in the red and I don't know
what not to pay
and still be able to live I guess okay
um I don't want to go behind on anything
but I it it's inevitable at this point
I'm pretty sure okay
how old are you guys
uh I'm 31 my life is 30. how long you
been married
uh Five Years on Friday what's your
household income
uh she would be uh 100 and 112 000. okay
so you make good money
you know I mean a hundred thousands no
no slouch in Wichita Kansas dude
that's excellent yeah so what what's
causing the problems
well we I think where we're at right now
is
um after Christmas uh there are some
bills that I forgot about and uh we've
got a an almost one year old and uh
the hospital called on that and I got
entertainment playing with them and that
payment plan came out and it overdrafted
my account
and after that I'm just
trying to play catch up I guess on that
and it's just been one thing after
another
um my entire entire blow out on one of
the vehicles that he didn't retire for
that and another it's expensive right
now
um how much was the hospital bill that
came out of your account
uh that one was it's only it was a 223
220 payment was making 115 000 a year
222 does not put you in this mess
what other debts what else do you have
uh so so
um the we have two vehicles right now
um one of them we owe 4 500 on the other
one with a 6200 on
um the 6200 one is the one we're selling
by the way okay
um we've got uh my wife has around 30
000 in student loan
um the uh credit cards
um is right around fourteen thousand
um
in the house is a hundred and two
thousand
and what else is there
trying to think how much is the house
worth
uh how's the right now I haven't had it
appraised or anything but I'm I'm
thinking that I could get around 140 to
100. so your house payment's not like
insane it's not like you guys live in a
half a million dollar million dollar
house
so Cole I mean you know
yes I understand this is it's
overwhelming and there's a lot of
numbers here but also
um
this could work so my question is month
to month do you guys are you is your
lifestyle just completely out of control
are you guys just spending a ton
um no without no you got a lot of money
going somewhere that you haven't shown
us yet
yeah oh daycare too so 300 a week going
to daycare what's your wife make a year
uh she makes 52 okay was that part of
the 112
yeah that's part of it yeah I make I
make 62 she makes 52. okay okay the only
thing I can think of is
um you're completely chaotic and
disorganized to the point that you're
out of control yeah
that's the only explanation because
there's nothing there's nothing glaring
in these numbers I kept waiting for the
fifty thousand dollar car
and it wasn't here
I kept waiting for something big that
was smacking these smacking this budget
in the mouth and it's not here so the
only thing I can come up with is you
guys must be some of the most
disorganized completely chaotic people
that I've run into in a while
yes I would agree with that that's right
we're jumping on with this we want to
get it you know that's fair I'm not
picking that's not I'm just trying to
help you trying to figure out where this
is going so I know how to fix it I'm not
picking on you okay because I'm I'm I I
get that so here okay that's bad news
and that's good news the good news is
that you're the problem the bad news is
you're the problem so we can fix this
okay really quickly so a detailed
in-depth game plan where you tell every
dollar exactly what to do every single
month and you and your wife pinky
swearing spit shake that you're not
doing a freaking thing with a single
penny except what you agree to on this
hardcore plan
we'll get you out of this really fast
you're gonna turn around so fast and
call that plan is you're not you're not
going out to eat you guys aren't
amazoning stuff to the house you're not
shot like you're doing you're literally
doing off Amazon Prime you're doing
nothing but catching up on these bills
because they're not going out to eat you
can do this call I mean the numbers are
here that I'm like no vacation this
summer you're broke people
yep no eating out you're broke people
you don't see the inside of a restaurant
unless you're working there as your
extra job to clean this freaking mess up
okay so this is like put yourself in
financial boot camp because here's the
thing you two are not dumb people
and if I hired you and said I'll give
you ten thousand dollars to look at
these people's budget and tell them
exactly what to do with it you'd have it
done in an hour and a half
yeah so here's what you do you take care
of food first
lights and water a second
pay the house payment third
you pay the car payments forth you put
gas in the car fifth you don't need any
clothes you got enough this month yep
okay Buy close only when there's
something that's completely about to
fall off of somebody or whatever right
now you've got people got clothes in
their closet for days I don't don't talk
to me about style you're broke people
okay and so you know this is what you do
this well Sharon and I did all right and
so you could turn this around really
fast we call that the four walls you
take care of the Four Walls of your
house the necessities of life food
shelter clothing Transportation
utilities gas in the car and everything
else can wait yeah
well it won't have to by the way when
you start writing this out you've got
enough room in this budget to probably
pull this off
I don't hear the payments because you're
not paying making any payments on the
stupid student loan
it's not affecting anything and if you
just throw the credit card payments in
the in the trash for one month
whoop-dee-doo
oh I hurt my credit well good you don't
need credit you're not really good with
it
yep okay exactly and so if you guys and
honestly I'm like where you guys are
there's almost this like radical
Behavior change that needs to occur on a
very radical scale because you've been
on one extreme I'm like and I know you
have a one-year-old but honestly I'd say
you know between now and July do Uber
Eats at night for for four months just
just do make some extra like you guys
need to like not get ubereats delivery
but like shock the system Cole you and
your wife honestly shock the system for
a short period of time and hold on the
line Austin will pick up we'll give you
guys Financial Peace University yeah go
through the Financial Peace University
because honestly you you guys got this
you could do this you get that every
dollar budget out tonight you and your
wife sit down and say okay we can eat we
got the money we can do the we keep the
lights on we can keep the house payment
paid you can do all those things and the
rest of it you just got to fight through
and you can do this